uh for those of you who don't know me
i'm nick risco one of the instructors
here at the st
louis chess club this is chess openings
explained and we're going over the
anti-martial
uh anti-marshals plural actually as uh
there are a couple different tribes
white has to avoid this attack
so for those of you who weren't here
last week i'll briefly cover the
marshall just so we know what we're
avoiding
uh and then we'll get right into it
so it comes from the rui lopez which is
e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6 and bishop b5
and i'm going to go through these next
few moves rather quickly as we've
covered the rui lopez on the channel
before
this was all covered last week a bunch
of other great content creators out
there
cover these first seven or eight moves
now last week we looked at what happens
if black
castles on move 7 which is an
alternative to playing d6 and when they
castle
first and white plays c3 black gets
pawn to d5 and this is the martial
attack also known as the marshall gambit
and here black gives up a pawn for a
huge lead in development
and a really crazy attack right off the
bat so after pawn takes
really there's no other move here for
white that's too
uh i guess mind blowing you might as
well just go for the free pawn
and when you do this after c6 and d4
starting with bishop d6 black really
gets uh gets going on white's king side
here rook to e1
saving the rook from the bishop queen to
h4
threatening uh mating type attack
so g3 is the only way to stop it now
after queen h3 bishop
e3 bishop g4 queen d3
rook 88 knight d2 and ricky six uh this
is the
the starting position of the marshall
that we looked at last week
and a lot of white players who may want
to play the roy lopez
but not deal with the martial attack
sometimes stay away from the roy lopez
just to avoid this attack
but there's a bunch of other great
positions you can get from the spanish
which are worth playing so let's talk
about how we avoid the marshall attack
and some other systems
that you can play so we'll back up
to move eight here after castles
now we can't go c3 unfortunately c3 just
brings d5 right away
now one of the first tries that someone
may come up with
is not too outstanding it equalizes
rather quickly
but not too crazy sharp is d4
after pawn to d4 black can take with the
knight we see a knight trade
and then rather than queen takes d4
right away
white gets a little bit of space a
little bit of tempo on black with e5
the knight has to go back to e8 and now
after
c3 c5 we see a take on d4
now black's not going to take back if
you take back the queen can just take
back right away
instead black is going to get a little
bit more space hit this bishop
it's going to go to c2 now we see black
play
pawn to d5 here in this position
um we see that each side is traded off
upon black has traded off their e pawn
white has traded off their c pawn and
here white's development can be rather
natural
we see a knight to c3 possibility this
bishop
is most likely going to go to e3 to
protect this d4 pawn just over protect
it
that way your queen can move around in
the future
whereas with black's play it's a little
bit
not as clear the knight can go to c7 and
e6 put pressure on d4
but this bishop loses a little bit of
scope here on the a3 to f8 diagonal
which really leaves it only operating on
the d8 to h4 diagonal
doesn't mean it's completely bad but
it's a you probably get more out of this
by choosing a different system uh
i guess as black i guess you don't
really have a choice because why is the
one who gets to play d4
but let's go through some more moves in
this system we have uh
knight to c3 knight to c7 both sides
rerouting the knights we see bishop to
e3 white's getting their last minor
piece off the back rank
and now black is going rook to b8
now the idea behind this is rather
straightforward you're just trying to
prepare a b4
push and then go b3
so something like a5 may come you may
just go b4 right away and that's
actually what we're going to see after
rook to c1
pawn to b4 hitting the knight the knight
has to retreat so we go to e2 again over
defending d4
we don't really want to go to b1 here if
we go to b1
this is just starting to to look a
little uh
scary for white with all the pieces here
on the queen side not really doing much
all kind of blocked in at least with
knight to e2 you're ready to go knight
f4 knight g3
and then uh followed up by queen to f3
or h5 you can have some great attacking
potential on the king side
after knight yeah knight to e2 you see
rook to b6
getting ready to swing it over to the
king side maybe
really staying flexible knight to f4
pawn to g6 just stopping any kind of uh
pieces coming in here now queen to f3
and queen to d7 and this is a rather
equal position
uh both sides have chances whites can
try to maneuver their pieces to get a
kingside attack
black is going to try and do the same
with their their bishops
and the queen pointing in this direction
the knight again is going to probably
hop to e6
and uh find some routes from there it's
also possible to go to b5 and d
not d6 but uh b5 and maybe try and get
something on d4 here but
probably better on e6 just centralize
the knight
but yeah that's the d4 line that's one
anti-marshal
but i think white actually has some much
better options here
we're going to start at looking with
pawn to h3
here so this is probably the second most
uh this is the second most popular let
me double check this real quick
um no actually h3 is the most popular
anti-martial
i apologize but we will take a look at
this line first
pawn to h3 what is one of the ideas
behind this move
one of the ideas here is that if black
so chooses they can go pawn to d6 and
after pawn to d6
white can go c3 and enter the normal
close roy lopez line something like the
chagoran
or the briar or the zaitsev this is
something that can come from this
position so
if you are really really comfortable
with those closed positions and really
trying to steer it back into that
direction after black castles first
pawn to h3 may be your move of choice uh
just because of this transposition
sometimes a lot of black players don't
know what to do after pawn h3
especially if they're like marshall
players
because they want to go d5 but here
after d5
e takes knight takes and then you take
this pawn on e5
and after c6 and d4 we actually noticed
a pretty big
difference here between the marshall and
this anti-martial line where after a
bishop to d6
we can just go rook e1 and this is
actually a better version
of the marshall but for white because
here white hasn't played c3 the knight
can go to c3 and trade itself off for
the knight on d5
and also black doesn't just have this
immediate queen to h4
threatening any type of mating attack
here so
white can really benefit from a little
bit of time
something like knight c3 here is uh very
natural
and then you'll be looking to make a
trade and
suddenly a lot of blacks attacking
pieces are disappearing
so that's one of the ideas of playing h3
first is
if they go for this martial attack idea
it doesn't exactly work out
um and so if uh martial players see that
doesn't really work out they typically
play
d6 or they can play the move
bishop to b7 here this is also very
natural something like the zaitsev where
the bishop goes to b7
now one of the drawbacks of bishop to b7
is that
this bishop you can argue is going to be
misplaced
um because if something like d3 here
which is actually the main line
uh the bishop is actually going to be
stopped by the e4 pawn
and later after something like d6 may go
back to c8 to go to e6 and trade itself
off for the light squared bishop
uh we have a question
in the previous position so i want to
make sure i answer that instead of just
blowing by it uh
with the h3 anti-marshall
we're getting questions in the chat if
after knight to c3
there's bishop takes h3 which is a good
question because this is a very common
idea in the
the regular marshall but here because
the knight is on c3
actually supports rook to e4 and you
start attacking the queen
so the queen has to leave the attack and
once the queen leaves the attack you can
take the bishop and be fine
your bishop controls this diagonal
and then your rook controls the g4
square so there's no like follow-up
checks by
black after rook to e4
but a very good question what happens if
they sacrifice
we'll go back to the b7 lines here after
bishop to b7 like i said one of the main
moves here
is pawn to d3 and first we're going to
look at pawn to c3 and see what happens
if white just tries to play this like a
normal spanish something with c3 and
then trying to go for d4 right away
and we'll get back into the d3 moves so
here after
pawn to c3 the most common reply is
pawn to d5 and i've actually had this
position against a feed a master
in a game and uh it was the first time i
actually saw this
line and uh it was rough
it was definitely rough i managed to
fight back and get
almost equal end game and then ended up
losing uh
losing because of uh a minor piece end
game i wasn't
i didn't have good enough pawns but um
the main thing to remember is after you
take and knight takes
white should be careful not to fall for
this trap
in the normal marshall attack it looks
like this pawn hangs and you get it and
then black gets this attack but you hold
on and you're good
but here if you take the pawn this is
actually losing on the spot because if
knight takes e5 rook takes e5
and knight to f4 and this move seems
innocent enough
but really what's happening is
everything's attacking g2 and there's no
way to really save it
you can try and go d4 make sure that
you're
opening up your lines for the rest of
your pieces and knight takes g2
and the move that i played in the game
was queen to g4
trying to go bishop to h6 and then try
and do some stuff here on the king side
but after knight h4 it was all shut down
because after bishop to h6 there is uh
just knight to f3 which is a fork uh
there's also
knight g6 that just holds the position
so unfortunately this uh this doesn't
work for white
but as long as white is aware that
taking the pawn in this position is
poison
they can play pawn to d3 and really this
just opens up the position for the
bishop for the knight to come in
you can try and get this pawn later but
uh
really rather not go for it um in some
lines but here after queen d7 it's it's
more than fine
you get the tempo on the queen after
rookie five then bishop f6
hitting the rook and now the rook comes
back just a normal move saving the rook
we see our rook come to the center and
rather than trade we don't want to give
black the file for free we leave the
rook here on e1
and develop the knight instead
uh here black has this very interesting
move
knight takes c3 and the idea is that
black is actually going to get a few
pawns for this knight because after b
takes bishop takes c3 rook b1 you don't
just want to give them the exchange
queen takes d3 black has sacrificed
tonight
four three three pawns here
what is what is black getting out of
this well
uh first we trade off rooks uh
because we don't want any uh of them
coming down and then
trying to uh take on d2 with the temple
on the queen and then our rook hanks
but we see bishop c2 and after queen to
d5
uh black is starting to get some counter
attack here on white
so uh i see some people in the chat say
c3 is not much of a good move after h3 i
know that is the point that is why i'm
covering this line
just to show what happens i'm not
recommending c3 i think it's dubious
there there is better um but after queen
to f3 to stop this mate attack
after uh this move it's rather equal
it's not
not too great your your bishop looks
good this bishop will will slowly become
better after this knight moves
but your rook isn't really doing much
staring at this pawn you may try
a4 later so this is an idea but i don't
i don't recommend it here um c3
probably not the best that's why most
players here play pawn to d3
in general whenever the bishop's on b7
playing d3 can be pretty good
and this is because once this knight on
c6 moves
then the bishop is staring at a pawn
that's protected by another pawn
so this bishop is going to be very
limited in what it actually controls
now here we normally see d5 trying to
break open the position a little bit
don't want to be completely closed we
see a trade
and now knight takes e5 now instead of
taking on e5
uh black does have this other option
here of knight d4 i
believe it's a little more popular and
after knight d4
white can just continue with normal
development normally in the rui
this light square bishop is very strong
you want to keep it on the board
but here with the position so open you
can't excuse me you can't afford to just
uh try and keep moving and saving the
bishop
you're gonna have to trade it for some
nights so you want to just keep up your
development
just go knight c3 now after knight b4
instead of just taking on b3 trying to
put some pressure on c2 here
open up the bishop and go knight e4
knight takes b3 ab3 queen d5
and now this knight is pinned now one
thing you need to
to be careful about is just you know
make sure you're not moving this knight
because you you can get mated
so we see knight to f3 and the idea is
that it's blocking off this diagonal
it's not really that it's just saving
the knight because if you tried to just
save the knights
you can try e4 or sorry d4 but
knight f3 saves the knight and blocks
this diagonal so it's stopping kind of
two threats at once
now after pawn to f5 which would be the
problem with
pawn to e4 d4 is uh this knight has to
move so the knight moves to g3
and now we see this knight on f3 saving
us from mate
and here black can go queen d7 and
there's a game from here
about triple zeros
okay so uh this knight d4 idea exists
there is also the knight takes e5 idea
where after rookie five queen d6 is a
move here but i think
white is a little bit better the pieces
aren't really coordinating
with each other here on the king side
compared to some of the other lines
rook a to e8 is a very standard move
it's
pretty much an automatic move for any
martial player
um knight to d2 pawn to c5 gaining space
maybe trying to go c4 in the future
d3 is stopping that currently we see
knight to e4
just hitting the queen the queen has to
move and again now we start to see some
coordination between the black pieces
where the queen is in front of the
bishop so again you have to be careful
of this g2 square
here white actually has this almost
awkward looking
c4 push um
here just encouraging a little bit of a
trade maybe create a weakness on a6
and we see the knight retreat to b6 now
what if white just tries something like
pushes it would try and make
it actually make a little bit of sense
if they push shut down this uh
queen side and then the light square
bishop looks awkward but here just
bishop to a4 is a skewer you are going
to win material
so that's why knight to b6 rather than
pushing or taking
so pawn to f3 is now shutting down this
diagonal because black
is threatening f5 in this position just
f5 and mate
so you go f3 to close down this diagonal
bishop to h4 just taking advantage of
the exposed dark squares rook to e3
and now queen to c7 queen may be looking
to come down but it
doesn't necessarily work and
here probably queen e2 and this position
is um is doable for white nothing
too wrong here something like knight f6
may be coming
just trying to take on e8 twice
a few different attacking ideas this uh
bishop can come to d2 and c3
or later you may try and go bishop d2
and e1 trying to trade off the dark
square bishops
try and trade off one of those attackers
bring the other rook to e1
this bishop can go to c2 and you can
push or you can just leave it
hoping that black will take and you can
go bishop a4 later
but nothing too crazy just
the main ideas in these positions is you
need to make sure that you're
careful of this a8 to h1 diagonal make
sure you're not getting checkmated
okay so that kind of covers the uh the
h3 lines here
there i don't think there's really
anything more than that in these lines
to to be aware of you just need to be
careful of this diagonal
and then in the line with bishop b7 and
then they go d5 just make sure you don't
take on e5
with the knight you don't want to run
into that knight f4 move
and now we're going to get into really
the main anti-marshal whenever someone
says anti-martial
this is the position that uh they think
of
um we're seeing black can get good
positions yes black can get good
positions the rui is one of the most
heavily analyzed
and uh no one's been able to bust it
um at least like completely bust black
uh
black's defense but uh here our main
move for tonight
is pawn to a4 so i'll let this kind of
marinate for a little bit
see what's popping up in the chat what
does chat think about this move
why might this move be played why are we
focusing on
the edge of the board i thought in the
opening we're supposed to worry about
center control
um so i'll give this a second to see
what chat has to say about this move
nick weiss is saying b4 yes that's the
response but that
doesn't answer the question of why we
play this move
why does white go for a4
xo in the chat is saying it's a move
trying to try and activate
the a rook this can be true if black
allows white to capture on b5 but as
nick weiss said b4 is possible so
exo what is the plan if they play b4 if
they play b4
it kind of goes against that idea you
gave me
all right we see another idea to make a
square for our bishop so the light
square bishop going back to a2
that does exist in some lines um
here uh if you just go bishop a2
immediately unprovoked it doesn't really
help but
it is an idea there if your bishop gets
attacked
so that is one idea
but um i do want to make the
counterpoint that if the only idea is to
preserve the bishop
um you know why why aren't we playing
some other move why not a3
why a4 over a3
exo is saying you try and play it like a
rui lopez with d3
but the pawn on b4 looks weak um
that pawn on b4 is actually not too weak
it's protected by the knight and bishop
and then if you play d3 right away black
actually gets in the move pawn a5
and that pawn on b4 is not going to be
too terribly weak and then after
something like
maybe knight a7 and c5 c5 will help
protect the pawn knight can go back to
c6 but these are all just rather quick
moves that come to the top of my mind
on you know
the the claim that b4 looks weak
so part of the idea here uh
we're kind of around the right idea is
so you do have this retreat square in
the future
now why a4 over a3 well
a4 forces black to make a decision
already on
how they want to handle this position
so they can either take they can push or
play bishop b7
but here um i need to explain why bishop
b7 is one of the moves yes it's a
logical developing move but also
white has this uh very quick threat here
of just taking on b5
and black cannot take back because they
will lose a rook
so black does need to do something about
this pawn now capturing
not really the best the bishop can just
capture and you're doing great
there's no problems with this this a6
pawn will be a weakness because there is
no b
pawn to defend it whereas here all of
white's pawns are
still connected it's going to be a
fairly pretty
pawn structure so in this position
uh probably better for white just
because a6 will be a weakness now this
is another big reason
why a4 if they push um
b4 you get this move a5 and then the
pawn on a6 will become weak and we'll
get back to this in just a second
i do want to cover the other move bishop
to b7
because now the idea is if white takes
well now black is allowed to take back
and white has to take
and here actually queen takes is
probably the best move and now after
this knight moves
away maybe not to d8 maybe a5 is more
accurate but this e4 pawn is going to
come under a lot of fire
so d3 here makes a lot of sense um
but there's no problem on the queen side
anymore for black it's not like white is
just shoving the pawn all the way up
through in their position
so rather than capture on b5 uh we'll go
d3
and this is kind of what uh exo was uh
touching on was that
you can kind of play it like a slow rui
lopez with d3
again if the bishop's on b7 in general
d3
is a good move because it uh blocks the
bishop's control on the center
and now we see black play pawn to d6
there's no reason to take here
um you don't want to break this tension
between pawns unless there's a very good
reason to do so
so here after d6 one of the ideas behind
this
is that the light square bishop now that
it's kind of blocked by these pawns on
d3 and e4
may want to reroute to c8 and e6
and challenge this light square bishop
that white has this is something i
mentioned earlier
this is one of those positions where
that idea exists
um here if they try b4
here after d3 it's still playable and
it's kind of like the main line
except the light square bishops are
going to remain on the board
and we'll see uh what it looks like in
just a bit
so look after a5 d6 knight d2
uh there is a bit of a change in the
main line with the light square bishops
we'll touch on that in a second but
after d6
knight to d2 um no need to move the
bishop it's helping
ready to capture on a4 and why not
develop
this dark square bishop first
one of the struggles that you can have
in white with rui lopez is knowing what
square is best for this bishop on
c1 it's unclear if it wants to stay on
c1
if it wants to go to e3 or if it wants
to go on g5
even d2 in some positions so rather than
try and force it to go somewhere
you just go knight to d2 and that is
going to be
flexible enough and white can just go
for some similar
developing moves we are seeing that um
d5
in this position is playable um
by nick weiss but i don't think it's uh
too stellar i think you can just take it
and then after the knight takes
you can take on b5 if you want and now
you have uh
two pawn islands white also has two pawn
islands but um
this pawn on e5 is temporarily a target
and if you try uh i guess white has to
take on a8
i guess you're taking back with the
bishop because if you take with the
queen the knight hangs
so bishop takes and you start to lose
some of this control on the diagonal
that you would have had if you played d5
earlier
and here now i think the the e pawn does
hang if you take on e5
just rook takes e5 you're hitting d5 and
e7
um this looks fine for white
i don't see where the counter play is
coming from black because the queen
can't easily develop
on a diagonal to threaten mate
nj pham is asking why knight b to d2 and
not knight c3
and i've been seeing your comment this
entire time about the uh
juco piano and this is a lecture on the
marshall
i'll take your requests but just ask
once we don't need to see it a bunch of
times
but why not knight c3 so one of the
ideas in the roy
and also the italian um is that
you want to play c3 and d4 now
i'm not saying you should go for that
plan right away but if the opportunity
comes up that's something you would want
to play
uh knight c3 is also playable here
though you do
put more pressure on b5 so that's a plus
going for it
but this does give black the chance to
go knight a5
and try and hit your bishop you can take
on b5 first or just bishop a2
and then after b4 the knight gets kicked
and it's going to have to move to e2
so it's not like the knight gets to go
to c3 and d5 for free
black does have this little inner meso
idea of kicking this knight away
so as long as you're okay with this
knight going to e2 and g3 that's fine
but i don't think we should be just
allowing the pawn to come up for free i
think if you're wanting to knight to go
on g3
going with this knight to d2 it can go
to f1 and then g3
so a little bit more of a flexible plan
here still allowing pawn to c3
the knight goes to f1 where it can
either go to g3 or e3
whereas if it's on e2 it can really only
go to
to g3 here
um and here there are quite a few moves
that black can try
i think we'll cover
cover knight a5 here
so after knight a5 bishop a2
black normally goes for c5 getting more
space on the queen side here
and the only problem right not really a
problem just a little drawback to this
move
is that uh d5 is now a fantastic outpost
square if a knight lands on that square
it's gonna be very difficult to get it
off without trading off pieces
white's struggle is if they can occupy
it with a piece in time for it to be of
any value
so we go knight to f1
wanting to go to e3 and d5
and now pawn to b4 getting more space on
the queen side here we see pawn to c3
uh pawn takes pawn takes and c4
trying to challenge in the center here
and now something like knight g3 is fine
just normal development
and cd3 queen d3 this knight could go to
f5 in the future
hit the bishop and the the pawn but
we're
taking care of our problems here in the
center first
and now bishop to c8 the idea of bishop
c8 is you don't want to allow the knight
to come to f5 so if knight f5
just bishop takes and you'll be fine
you'll have this
e pawn in the center that'll help and
the d-pawn can
come forward too so these pawns in the
center might be a problem
see bishop to a3 developing our last
minor piece
queen to c7 hitting this c pawn that may
be weak
rook e to d1 putting pressure on d6
and after knight b7 queen c4 and a trade
of queens this is the type of position
you could get
where white is slightly better because
of the the pieces
this bishop on e7 is not really doing
too hot same for the bishop on c8
it can go to d7 this is probably going
to be its best square but it can't
really go to
it can't go to f5 g4 you probably go
there
um probably just run into bishop e2 and
break the pin
but it's not clear where these pieces
are best placed this knight can go to c5
but after a trade leaves you with some
isolated pawns
that's going to be black's struggle here
is getting the pieces to
really great squares and being able to
coordinate
okay let's back up we will leave this
knight a5 idea
and i think we will back up further
away from this bishop b7 idea i think
we're gonna
focus more on the main line here and
look at what happens
if they play b4 so this is the the big
idea
nick weiss put in the chat earlier and
then after pawn to a4
is met with pawn to b4 and what this
does is it cramps white's position
and it prevents this knight from
developing to c3 so that was one of the
benefits of playing the uh
the h3 move earlier was if they went for
the marshall attack we can get knight c3
and trade off the knights or go rookie
four
driving the queen away um but here after
pawn to b4 we don't have this knight c3
idea
anymore so what to do
what do we do here in this position
i'll uh let you guys take a little bit
of time here and
see what your ideas are
how does white meet pawn to b4 we
already discussed that b4
looked like it could be a weakness but
really isn't the knight bishop do a good
job and
if black gets the chance a5 should
probably help them
nick uh we're seeing a rook a3
suggestion
maybe if you're playing anti-trust it
might be decent
give away all your pieces
strike the center with d4 it's a very
active idea does it actually work though
uh you can go d4 what do you do against
d6
exo has this idea of playing c3
instead of d4 i'll get to that in a
second but it's also a nice idea
and then strider thomas is also
recommending pawn to d3
so i think if you go d4 black just plays
pawn d6
and i don't see where white's getting
all the play
if you take on e5 taking back
either way looks like it should be fine
but we'll go with the pawn it's a little
bit more principled here
bishop g5 developing the piece and then
bishop b7 but here you don't have any
d-pawn left
to go d3 so this bishop is actually
pretty good on b7
and i don't know
i really don't know about that position
i i haven't looked at d4
um actually no i have looked at d4
because it's a
more popular variation now but yeah
after d6 takes
this should be fine for black
i guess the only trap that black can go
for is if they take d4 with the knight
is uh bishop f7 rook f7
and now the rook is hit and then after
rook f8
um after rook f8 there's queen takes d4
and white's
a bit better here about plus one just
because the activity
and if they go like 96 then
uh knight f7 king f7 and e5 is going to
win the game because uh after the night
moves there's queen f3 which is check
and hits the rook so yeah i did actually
look at this move d4
is fine um
i just got my uh moves mixed up here
move orders mixed up
after d6 and uh d takes e5
both captures are fine you're gonna end
up taking on e5 if they capture with the
knights
and queen e2 you leave the queens on the
board it's something like a5 and now b4
is secure so
uh yeah i apologize that uh d4 i
dismissed it so quickly
i just got the move orders mixed up all
right what were some of the other ideas
we had we had um
c3 c3 looked like a an interesting move
here
c3 does look rather interesting just
trying to uh get the pawn out of here
but black doesn't have to capture
and they also don't have to uh really
worry about it again it's defended
and white probably shouldn't want to try
and capture this way because it ruins
this idea of playing d4
supported by a pawn so after pawn to c3
maybe black even has some some
initiative with d5
take take and yeah we can go for this
idea of gambiting the pawn again and
after bishop to e6 we're holding
and i think black has a little bit too
much development here
this is still a fine position for both
sides but
i personally wouldn't want to give black
all this development
i guess we go d4 is the one of the only
moves here
but black does get some uh some activity
here and it starts to remind me a bit of
the marshall attack
where black does have play and i don't
want to invite that if i'm playing an
anti-martial i want to avoid ideas like
this
and then the other idea we had
was
to do d3 followed by bishop e3
and this is also very playable um after
d3 we
can see d6 and now the bishop's ready to
come to e6
it hasn't committed to b7 yet
and then here something like
a5 but really that's going to turn back
into the main line
so we'll leave this idea here
and go to the main line but yeah d4 is
possible c3 is possible but
the the move i'm going to recommend here
the move that uh
i found over the board the first time i
encountered this variation
is pawn to a5 and i didn't see anybody
in the chat recommend
this and i don't really blame them a5
looks a little
loosening for white it makes it look
like this pawn on a5 is going to be very
weak and get captured
but in return for this this pawn on a6
is actually fixed it can't move anywhere
and this pawn on a6
is typically going to be weaker than the
pawn on a5
um but here it may be pretty difficult
to claim white is so much better with
this move
and we'll get into how black can kind of
kill some of this play here
we see pawn to d6
and now here in this position main move
is d3 so he really just
transposed back into what was that idea
strider thomas put in the chat
i will also mention c3 here
here after the pawn is advanced to a5
this pawn can go to c3 because now this
pawn can't just come up and defend right
away
and this is the most popular move trying
to take care of this pawn right away but
i think most of the lines here have been
analyzed to a draw
or at least like dead equal end games
so we'll start off with uh black playing
rook
to b8 just adding another defender to
the pawn
bishop to c4 hitting the pawn on a6
maybe looking to go queen e2 next
now we see d5 we see the capture capture
and we don't capture on e5 here
after knight takes and rook takes bishop
to e6
we start to get some of that activity
back from
from black and now even if you try like
let's say you try and go bishop a6 here
this runs into queen d6 which is going
to hit the bishop and the rook
and then you're gonna have to sacrifice
your rook give up the exchange
not rook g5 that was a misclick um but
taking on d5
so don't take on e5 here black does get
the activity
you just go d4 continue developing
and now after b takes some knight takes
not really uh not really pawn takes here
because rook b1
while odd looking is actually playable
after
rook takes then knight to c3 and they
get the exchange back
so like queen b3 and after knight b1
queen b1 um i don't really like this for
white i think too many pieces have been
traded off
so that's why we go with the knight and
uh that way if the knight takes to
recapture with the pawn don't have any
uh weird ideas of the rook sacking on b1
so now knight takes pawn takes pawn
takes and then knight takes
if you go with the pawn you run into
bishop g4 and this can be an annoying
pin
trying to hold on to the pawn so that's
why we capture with the knight
just avoiding bishop to g4 and now after
all the trades on d4 we see bishop to b4
hitting a5 and e1 the rook goes to d1 to
support the pawn to push later
and we see a few more bishop moves and
rook moves
and this end game here after g6 has been
uh
played hundreds of times uh very
thoroughly
and after like 20 moves
it's like a draw so i'll go through uh
the moves here at least so you can see
them
but i'm not gonna waste all our time
analyzing all of these moves
we can see that the bishops get traded
off a pair of rooks get traded off and
we enter this drawn king and pawn end
game
so that's one of the positions you can
look forward to instead of the knight
taking on c3 there is also
bishop to e6 just developing but again
here this position has also been seen
many times and worked out to equality
after uh some trades in the center
and with no more real targets in the
center of the board
we see a queen trade we see a pawn sack
to ruin the pawn structure
and more maneuvering of the pieces
uh all very boring dry stuff and we get
this end game where
white has four pawns black has three
it's a knight versus bishop
but this is also a draw
so i think because of this rook b8 move
here
on move 10 c3 is probably not
going to be the most the most practical
move just because those end games have
been
worked out if you love your end games go
go for it
um but i think because of rook b8
already
this may be pretty difficult
uh against a well-prepped opponent i
should clarify
um the other thing with c3 i guess is if
they
take right away and this is the other
common move they just
trade it off uh you can take with either
pawn here taking with the b-pawn to help
support d4
or taking with the d-pawn i'm going to
recommend taking with the d-pawn
mainly so you can develop this bishop
either the g5 or e3
and have clear clear play with your
pieces and then this pawn can go to b4
and defend a5 later
you're not isolating this a pawn
okay bishop d7 knight b2 or d2 rather
queen to c8 this is just lining it up to
be on the light squares knight f1
we see all the knights remaneuver
and then uh g6 just stopping the knight
from going to f5
queen d3 king g7 and
there's two options here white can
either play b4
and then after c5 play rook b1
and just defend this b-pawn that way
after captures captures with the pawn
and after queen b7 white will develop
the dark square bishop to
probably e3 maybe d2 uh
and then just enjoy a spatial plus
if they don't want to play b4 they can
also go bishop e3 and it's playable but
this can lead to some awkward positions
where black can bounce white's pieces
around
we'll get into that here with knight to
g4 hitting the dark square bishop that
you just developed
you don't really want the knight to
trade itself for your bishop
the bishops are usually good pieces for
white
so we go bishop d2 and now after knight
c5 the queen is getting hit and you're
already
starting to see where i'm coming from
the knights are just hitting all the
pieces
they have to keep moving around after
bishop to e6
you have to do something about um this
excuse me this tension
after trades on c4 knight f6
i really don't like how black can just
force those moves
and then now after b4 the queens move
i think the other position can be a
little bit better just because you have
an extra set of pieces on the board
so that's my recommendation go for b4 if
you run into this line
uh let's see but yeah that that covers
um what can come from either rook b8 or
pawn takes c3
uh and those are the c3 lines like i
said those are the most popular
but i i don't i don't recommend those
here i'm going to recommend the move d3
and the idea of d3 is just playing it
like a slow rui
um this bishop isn't on b7 so you don't
get the whole
you know shutting out the bishop idea
but you still get this nice pawn chain
um you can go c3 later and d4 later
you just can't rush it right away so now
after bishop e6 which is the entire idea
of playing d6
and now you're going to bishop e6
challenging the bishop
you can just trade now black does get a
little bit out of this they do get
another pawn controlling the center
and they do get this half open file now
but
white can continue developing pieces
normally
and shouldn't be bad rook b8 an idea
again
the other idea here is queen to e8 and
if they go queen to e8 and this is
really just trying to come
on the light squares here well i can
play c3 and kind of develop their pieces
normally
we see rook b8 again but now d4 breaking
through in the center
rook b5 just to stabilize a little bit
to put some pressure on the a5 pawn
see a couple trades some maneuvering of
the pieces
and this position should be fine here
for white nothing too crazy to worry
about e5 is a little weak
in turn a5 is a little weak for white
but there is this big open file that
white should be able to take advantage
of with a rook to d1
so queen e8 maybe a little dubious
um what do i think about the rui lopez
with d3 instead of castles for white to
prevent marshals as well
um i'm not familiar with those lines but
we can take a look after this
but i am going to get through the last
few moves here
uh after c3 rook to b5 against
stabilizing putting pressure on a5
there is pawn to c4 and now i will cover
uh rook takes a5 if you see rook takes
a5
don't trade the rooks you can go rook to
b1
and now the idea is after something like
rook to b
sorry knight to b3 this rook is almost
trapped so you can go rook b1 but
the main move here is rook to b8
and now knight b3 um
helping control d4 gonna push d4 in the
future
see a couple queen moves
and we see this trade on d4 and
from here you start to get into your
middle game so i don't think i'm gonna
go
past this but exo has been waiting
patiently to see what i think about
going d3
first instead of castles so
we're gonna go back to the beginning uh
we are going to open this up
to questions so if you do have any
questions
just put them in the chat we'll get to
them so
exo i just want to clarify you're saying
d3 instead of castles
so playing d3 in this position
wow what's the idea with d3 here i guess
it kind of turns into a classical
but with a6
so i guess bishop c5 is a good try here
just developing
um i mean yeah this is a position
but it kind of reminds me of like um
like an anti-berlin i think that's what
it's called but like they go for a
berlin end game and you play d3 instead
that's what this looks like to me and i
feel like a lot of chances are lost here
for white
and it's equalized for black pretty much
already because they haven't had to make
any concessions
on the queen side with b5 and they just
get natural development of their pieces
and get a castle soon so
while it is playable it looks like you
do give up a lot of chances
it looks like they just go bishop c5 and
if you castle anyway
um i mean this just looks like like a
berlin except
that the the bishop's on a4 and the
pawns on a6
so if you're looking for equality there
you go but
i think as white you should be trying to
push for every little edge you can get
uh strider thomas made a comment about
the main line here
with um castles in a4
that white knight and bishop are not
developed and it's hard to consider
pawn to a5 after b4 that is true but uh
i do want to mention the position does
become locked up a little bit so time
isn't as big of an issue it's not like
the marshall where everything's open and
if you miss one move you're mated
um so a5 just kind of locks it up a
little bit more
and then like i said um this knight this
knight almost always goes to d2 and f1
and g3
um it can go to c3 in some lines
obviously not the b4 lines
um and then this bishop yeah the bishop
on c1 is the problem piece
most of the time not really that's bad
just not really knowing which square it
truly belongs on until later in the game
so uh yeah it's good to leave the bishop
back anyways be more flexible
but yeah you're kind of locking up the
position so you can play all these
developing moves without
black getting any more space than they
need to
all right that covers um yeah pretty
much covers all the main lines here
like i said um we do still have a couple
minutes four questions
so i will leave it open uh probably for
the next
two minutes and uh if we don't get
anything we will shut it down
you're welcome you're welcome strider
says thanks for the explanation it's
always a pleasure to be doing these
lectures for you guys i wouldn't be
doing it
if it wasn't fun uh it was really great
having you guys here tonight last
weekend this week very engaging
in the chat that always makes it more
pleasant for everybody involved
um if you are still going to be sticking
around for another hour we're actually
going to be moving to uh
twitch here shortly we're going to be
going uh to do a lecture
in the winter circle series we're
actually going to be covering rounds
11 12 and 13 of the 1953 zurich
candidates tournament
the game is played by smislov he was the
winner of that tournament so that's what
the winners circle is all about we pick
one tournament we get the winner of that
tournament go through their games so if
you guys are
sticking around make sure to hop over to
twitch we'll be covering that
shortly uh here
nicholas in the chat is saying do you
think chess 960 is the future of
chess uh well fisher's been
proposed it uh and
i think there hasn't really been any
more progress towards making it
um the future of chess i don't think
it's going to be the future of chess
um i do appreciate it as a variant but i
don't think it's the future
not until chess is solved i know the
idea is like opening prep is
killing the game of chess but i think um
i don't know i don't really see the
problem with it if opening prep
uh wasn't involved at all we wouldn't
have this lecture
uh njfam's asking in the chat is a
certain really
good and you're just talking about the
berlin that line is the berlin
uh yeah it's good it's fine it's solid
and then nicholas is asking would you
agree openings are generally
overemphasized by tutors and you can
drastically improve that chess with just
tactics and then game
i do agree that at the lower levels
opening should not be your main focus
learning tactics and the end game
are probably going to help the most but
it's also good just to take a look at
different openings not necessarily to
memorize lines
but just to understand the ideas behind
the opening so
taking a look at you know a dozen
different openings and seeing how
different
scenarios in the sensor on the wings can
be handled the piece
development i think that's good so you
can learn some of the general piece
placements but uh yeah pretty much i
think uh
you know you shouldn't be forcing 800s
to learn
openings and memorize lines because
that's not why they're rated 800.
it's because they hang a piece every
other move
great wolf is saying getting the knight
to c4 is a way to play this position
in which line
is there a specific line that you're
asking about putting the knight on c4
because the issue i have with putting
the knight on c4 is what squares are you
actually controlling
you're not really controlling anything
the pawn on c7 the pawn on d7 is going
to go to d6 and those pawns are going to
control
all the squares your knight can go to so
i don't think
this is good
i think the only square that's even good
for the knight to go to is e3
but why would you not just go to f1 and
then you have the choice of e3 or g3
both of which are good squares i think
just knight d2 to f1 is going to be the
best most flexible plan
with knight d2 to c4 you're really
committing yourself to putting the
knight on e3
and sometimes that may not be the best
position for the knight sometimes you
want your bishop on that square
so i i don't think knight to c4 is gonna
be
the plan here but it was a good question
i don't want to make it sound like i'm
bashing on you too much it was a
definitely a good question
all right you have any last minute
questions here before we switch over to
twitch
njfam is asking is 1100 rating beginner
or intermediate depends on who you ask
i think it's still beginner but to be
fair i think
anyone below 1500 is a beginner some
people say 1500 is intermediate
i think 1500 is kind of that threshold
but that's just my opinion
but yeah 1100 um
that's i mean you know something about
chess if you're 1100 you can checkmate
but
you're still going to be hanging pieces
or missing
missing opportunities
all right well i'm not seeing any other
questions pop up in the chat so we're
gonna end it here
thank you for coming and stopping into
chess openings explained
this will be published on youtube later
so you can go back and watch it again
um if there are any questions just drop
them in the comments section after it
gets published
i do my best to try and go back take a
look at them answer any questions
uh those suggestions you guys have for
other openings drop them down there
as well i think last week we got a
suggestion for the bishops opening so
we'll be covering that next week and
then we see um
people asking for the joker piano which
we will cover eventually but i think the
italian just has a lot of theory it's
gonna have to be multi-part
but yeah i just want to thank everyone
again we're gonna end it here on youtube
and we're